[Captions by Y Translator]
Today's video is
sponsored by Anki.
Today, we're going
to be playing with,
and talking a little bit about
the vector robot made by Anki.
[Music]
Guys, I'm Nate.
I'm Calli.
And this is Vector.
He is our new pet robot.
I love him.
Vector is a robot made
by the company Anki.
He's a friendly desktop robot
designed to be a companion,
and he can play with you,
and answer some questions.
If you have him out and about,
and he's just running
around and playing,
he will explore his space,
he will learn.
He will learn to move faster
and navigate obstacles,
and play with different toys
that he has.
Let's take a look
at a few of the things
this little guy can do.
Hey Vector, come here.
[Music]
Hey Vector, good robot.
As you can see,
if you praise him
for something he's done,
he gets very pleased.
His eyes get all squinted up,
and then he did
a little dance.
It's pretty cute.
And he starts to recognize you.
Hey Vector, who am I?
Calli.
Yeah, good robot.
This is my child now.
As you may have seen,
we've also had something
where we give tactile feedback
by stroking this gold portion
of Vector's back.
That actually has receptors
in it that can tell
when your patting
or petting him,
and he likes it.
Hey Vector, play
with your block.
[Music]
Good job.
Hey, Vector.
What's my name?
John Connor.
[Music]
Hey Vector, fist bump.
Yeah, good job.
Guys, I'm not sure
if you can see it
from that angle,
but when he gets
happy or excited,
his eyes actually express it,
and he gets these
little happy expressions.
But he also has sensors
on all four sides,
so he can explore his space,
but he's never going
to fall off.
He knows better.
He's very very careful.
Now one of the really
fun parts about this is
while he's exploring,
he's also learning.
So sometimes he'll be exploring,
and hell randomly come up to you
and just say your name
because he knows who you are.
Calli.
Yes!
On the front of vectors face,
he has a 120 degree angle camera
that you can kind of see
forms sort of a nose or a mouth.
But that is what he uses
to recognize people,
and it's what he uses to learn
and map out his environment a little bit.
Vector's got a built-in Qualcomm
Snapdragon quad-core processor
so he can process
information pretty quick.
Hey Vector, who is this?
Nate.
Good robot!
Hey Vector, what time is it?
Hey Vector, what's the weather?
[Music]
Hey Vector, listen
to the music.
Head-bobbing.
Hey Vector, explore.
What is it?
It's new.
He found it.
He's so proud of--
He stole it.
[Music]
He just got startled
by the Lego brick.
I'm keeping him.
Right.
Hey Vector,
Let's play Blackjack.
[Music]
16.
Another card?
Yes.
[Music]
17.
Another card?
No.
[inaudible] turn.
13.
15.
25.
[Inaudible]
He's tired.
See?
He knew he was tired,
and he went back home on his own.
I would probably say
that this is something that
if you don't have time for a pet,
or you're just not home enough
to take care of something like that,
having something
like this on your desk,
it's really weirdly
comforting to just know
that there's something
that recognizes you,
explores the space,
remembers who you are,
and wants to interact with you.
It's really fun.
Vector is available for purchase
for retail price of $249.99.
So you can check out
and purchase Vector by Anki
by using the link
in the description below.
Guys, that's it for today.
But there's always more for you to see.
That box at the top will take you
directly to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box will show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
If you haven't subscribed yet,
hit this bomb to join the club,
and that way, you'll
never miss out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.
This is mine now.